WE ARE GOING TO GET TO SOME
OTHER REALLY IMPORTANT NEWS ON
COVID IN A MOMENT BUT RIGHT NOW
SOME BREAKING NEWS OF THE
BORDER.
DESPITE BIDEN’S DENIALS OF A
CRISIS BREWING,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS
REPORTED MOMENTS AGO THAT THE
NUMBER OF UNACCOMPANIED MIGRANT
CHILDREN DETAINED ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER HAS TRIPLED IN
THE LAST TWO WEEKS ALONE.
TO MORE THAN 3,250.
MORE THAN 1360 OF THE CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN DETAINED BEYOND THE 72
HOURS PERMITTED BY LAW BEFORE A
CHILD MUST BE TRANSFERRED TO A
SHELTER.
JOINING ME NOW A
SENATOR TOM COTTON.
I KNOW HE WANTS ANSWERS.
SENATOR, WHY IS JOE BIDEN
WAITING UNTIL LATER THIS WEEK
FOR A BRIEFING FROM HIS TEAM ON
THIS GROWING SECURITY,
HEALTH-RELATED AND HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS OF HIS OWN MAKING?
>> HEY, LAURA.
GOOD TO BE ON WITH YOU AND
THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION.
WE HAVE A CRISIS OF THE BORDER.
THIS IS THE BIDEN BORDER CRISIS.
JOE BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS MAY
NOT THINK IT’S A BORDER CRISIS
BECAUSE I DON’T BELIEVE IN
BORDER SO BY DEFINITION THEY
DON’T THINK THERE CAN BE A
CRISIS OF THE BORDER BY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A CRISIS.
THIS WAS ALTOGETHER PREDICTABLE.
PREDICTED.
I SAID LAST YEAR DURING THE
CAMPAIGN YOU CANNOT PROMISE
AMNESTY AND OPEN BORDERS IN
HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL ALIENS
AND NOT EXPECT A MIGRANT CRISIS
OF THE BORDER.
WHAT’S HAPPENED?
NOT JUST IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS
BUT EVERY MONTH SINCE THE
ELECTION WE HAVE SEEN INCREASED
NUMBERS AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
THEY SENT A TEAM TO ASK ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WERE ENOUGH
TEACHERS THERE OR WHAT THE
ACCOMMODATIONS WERE FOR KIDS.
HOW ABOUT THE TEAM ASKS WHAT ARE
WE DOING TO STOP IT AND TURN THE
MIGRANTS BACK AND TELL THEM IT’S
NOT THE WAY TO COME TO AMERICA.
>> Laura: THE PRESS SECRETARY
FOR PRESIDENT BIDEN TODAY SAID
THAT THEY HAVE TO BASICALLY BE
BETTER WITH THEIR MESSAGING ON
THIS.
IS THIS AN MESSAGING PROBLEM
WHEN YOU HAVE 180 KIDS, 30 KIDS
UNDER THE AGE OF 13.
SOME OF WHOM ARE KEPT IN THESE
CEMENT CELLS THAT THEY WERE
GETTING ON TRUMP FOR HAVING TO
KEEP PEOPLE IN TEMPORARILY UNTIL
HE’S BASICALLY SOLVED THE BORDER
PROBLEM.
>> NO, LAURA.
WHEN A POLITICIAN TELLS YOU THAT
IT MEANS THEY HAVE A REALITY
PROBLEM.
THEIR REALITY PROBLEM IS THAT
THEY CREATED A CRISIS AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER BY INVITING THE
ENTIRE WORLD TO SHOW UP AND
CLAIM ASYLUM.
DONALD TRUMP TURNED AWAY PEOPLE
WHO WERE SEEKING ASYLUM AND TOLD
HIM TO STAY IN MEXICO AND THAT
THEIR CLAIMS COULD BE
ADJUDICATED IN AN ORDERLY
FASHION FROM MEXICO.
JOE BIDEN’S ADMINISTRATION IS
SEEKING OUT THOSE ILLEGAL ALIENS
THEN DONALD TRUMP TURNED AWAY
AND INVITING THEM TO COME BACK
TO THE BORDER.
WE HAVE GONE FAR BEYOND CATCH
AND RELEASE.
THIS IS A RECRUITING RELEASE.
ALMOST ALL OF THESE CLAIMS WILL
BE REJECTED.
THE SIMPLE FACT IS IF YOU’RE
FROM CENTRAL AMERICA AND YOU’RE
SEEKING ASYLUM, YOU DO THAT AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER OF MEXICO.
WHEN YOU GET ALL THE WAY TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER OF THE
UNITED STATES YOU’RE NO LONGER
SEEKING ASYLUM.
YOU ARE SEEKING A BETTER JOB AND
BETTER LIVING CONDITIONS.
>> Laura: THEY WERE SENT OUT
OF THE UNITED STATES IMMEDIATELY
DURING COVID BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE BRINGING PEOPLE